ça vous avez que jérôme marty les
médecins généralistes président de
l'union française pour une médecine
livre jérôme marty merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france bonsoir
alors on le constate dans le nombre de
contaminations ne cesse d'augmenter
montpellier toulouse passe en zone d'
alerte maximale dès demain 1 et a
prolongé de 15 jours pour marseille à
paris
les taux d'occupation des lits de
réanimation est préoccupant dans
certaines zones placées en alerte
maximale
la médecine de ville est-ce qu'elle
aussi elle est dans le rouge aujourd'hui
oui elle est dans le rouge à lèvres
rouge déjà depuis plusieurs semaines
vous savez que c'est la médecine de
ville et qui a lancé les alertes un peu
juillet à luton disant attention ça
reprend que trop souvent on nous a
opposé le fait qu'il n'y avait à
l'époque pas d'hospitalisation et que
donc il ne se passe rien et on a perdu
les temps par rapport à ça alors ce
qu'il faut comprendre c'est que
actuellement les cabinets sont croule
sous les demandes de soins parce que les
100 % des gens consultent dans la mesure
où là où habituellement vous ne
consultez pas pour un rhume on court un
peu température mal de tête
là vous consulter parce que vous voulez
savoir si oui ou non vous êtes appel
ducobu 19 vous avez déjà d'une
ordonnance pour aller et c'est légitime
pour aller faire un test
et donc nous avons énormément énormément
de demandes de soins nous sommes
confrontés à la maladie au cog hill 19
tous les jours quasi et nous sommes pas
sûrs d'avoir là encore les moyens de
protection puisque je le rappelle il
faut impérativement que tous les
soignantes du pompier en passant par les
deux soignantes infirmières les médecins
disposent de masques ffp2 puisque vous
le savez c'est maintenant reconnu enfin
le mode de contamination c'est l'aérosol
isation et donc il faut des masques
étranges pour les soignants alors selon
vous est-ce qu'il faut prendre des
mesures fortes tout de suite on sait que
tient un conseil de défense qui va avoir
lieu dans les prochains jours il faut
réellement prendre des mesures fortes
aujourd'hui il faut surtout que chacun
soit conscient de son rôle passé c'est
une somme de combat et de combat
individuel qui fait la victoire
collective chacun doit respecter les
mesures barrières il faut maintenant que
je reconnais sans conditions de la
présence de ce virus sur tout le
territoire à la différence de mars avril
où il était présent principalement dans
l'est de la france et sur
l'ile-de-france là on a une âme virale
qui recouvre tout le territoire
certes nous ne sommes pas dans la même
configuration que mars et avril mai mais
nous avons l'eau service de l'animation
qui sont en train de se remplir parce
qu'on dispose de moyens de l'y
paradoxalement que l'époque puisqu'on ne
peut pas des programmes et toutes les
opérations où tous les patients qui
doivent aller en réanimation pour
d'autres pathologies
et fort heureusement il faut s'occuper
d'eux aussi donc ça veut dire qu'il faut
impérativement que chacun d'entre nous
joue son rôle
pour éviter que cette épidémie juste
davantage alors moins de lits
aujourd'hui vous vous le disiez est-ce
que l'exécutif avait réellement le temps
après la première vague de réarmer de
réorganiser l'hôpital selon vous le
temps normalement si vous voulez on est
honnête on est là sur les conséquences
des politiques sanitaires successives
qui se substituent qui ont eu lieu
depuis des années des années et qui ont
fait que on ajuste ses lits de
réanimation
on peut en activant le privé en activant
les établissements participant au
service public dégager des lits en plus
mais le problème est pas là le problème
c'est que depuis le confinement depuis
le levé du confinement le 11 mai je
rappelle il ya quatre mois
on avait le temps en tout cas de mettre
en place une politique de prévention une
politique de tests qui permettent
réellement de lutter contre cette
épidémie et 2 d'empêcher sa propagation
on reçoit appelle maintenant les tests
antigénique on nous dit comment les
avants dans nos cabinets c'est une
demande que l'on fait depuis plusieurs
semaines là aussi on a mis trop de temps
on a bloqué deux laboratoires en
demandant à tous les gens d'aller se
faire tester et on a mis en l'air
complètement on a mis à bas
notre politique de test et donc on ne
peut pas casser et donc on ne peut pas
isoler et puis parallèlement on a mis
des mois et des mois et des mois à
reconnaître ce problème de contamination
par l'aérosol isation et donc on n'a pas
dit aux gens d'aérer et donc
certainement
on a favorisé la propagation de
l'épidémie à l'usmba des bons des bonnes
règles alors justement avec votre
syndicat unef ml vous allez attaquer
l'état pour manquements dans la
protection des soignants alors pour quel
motif plus précisément et qu'est ce que
vous attendez aujourd'hui cette
procédure alors en fait on accompagne de
famille que l'on d'efforts
c'est n'avons pas lu et femelles qui les
déforme la famille baud la vie si la
famille welling qui sont des confrères
qui ont malheureusement qui sont décédés
yoko ville 19 ce que l'on dit c'est que
l'état si vous voulez n'a pas fait tout
ce qu'il devait faire pour protéger les
soignants et donc il y à un manquement
un devoir de protection à une profession
dont il a la charge
dans la mesure où elle est face au coc
u19 dans une mission de santé publique
c'est pas du tout comme quand on exerce
pour une autre mission là on est
véritablement dans une mission de santé
publique convenez que nous recevons tous
les jours des fiches d'orientation des
ars il nous demande de modifier nos
pratiques l'organisation de l'eau
cabinet etc
donc on est véritablement dans une
fiction santé publique on est en quelque
sorte dans cette mission là des agents
de l'état et donc nous devons être
protégé ça n'a pas été fait puisque
quantité de médecins aient été
contaminés mais également d'infirmières
dans d'autres professions santé nous
disent que lorsqu'ils cherchaient des
masques début mars il ne pouvait pas en
trouver et les pharmaciens le vent d
espoir les écouter on est désolé mais on
n'en dispose pas et donc ils ont
consulté sans moyens de protection et
malheureusement certains en sont
décédées merci beaucoup jean marty
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes médecin
généraliste président de l'unef mlc
l'union française pour une médecine et